Speaker 1: So I hate to start the week with
something so depressing and so negative and so
horrifying, but we really need to recontextualize
the embarrassing, humiliating vaccination
situation in which we find ourselves in the United
States in a situation where increasingly the right
is focused on authoritarian Joe Biden because
of his so-called vaccine mandates announced last
week. Now, remember the vaccine mandates announced
last week, like, for example, if you have over 100
employees, you need to require a vaccination from
them or they can just be tested every week. So,
like, there's a pretty simple way not to have
to get vaccinated even in those cases. But even
still, they are being called vaccine mandates
and the right is focused on its authoritarian.
It's not. And it's illegal and it's not. And
it's unprecedented, but it's not. And all of
this different stuff, the context in which this is
happening is a context in which the United States,
here we go, is quickly becoming the least
vaccinated, wealthy country in the world,
the least vaccinated. We had all the vaccines
earlier than anybody. We created some of the
vaccines, at least partially. American companies
manufactured the vaccines. We had dibs. We had
it all. And yet the United States is quickly
declining in vaccinations per 100 people per
capita and will soon be the least vaccinated of
the wealthy countries. And it is for one reason.
We have an overwhelming number of a special breed
of ignorant political extremists whose ignorance
has been channeled, could have been channeled
into other things. The ignorance has now been
channeled into thinking they shouldn't get the
vaccine either for political reasons. They don't
want to make Joe Biden look good by getting
vaccinated or they don't trust the vaccine and
they've fallen for other conspiracy theories
about it was rushed or it changes your DNA
or at MAGNETIZE as you are at demagnetize is
your world, who knows, whatever we are globally
a joke. We are so humiliated. But the very people
who are making us be humiliated aren't paying
attention to what's going on globally anyway. And
if they were, they wouldn't care. They would say
those CESI Europeans, who cares if they think
that we are idiots. Other countries look at us
and they say, hey guys, send the vaccines to
the countries that want them. We have countries
where as soon as we get five and a vaccine
supply for five percent of the population,
we vaccinate five percent and then we get to
fifty percent and fifty five percent and on
and on. If you have all these anti-tax morons,
they are saying elsewhere, send us the vaccines.
So let's look at the numbers. Start with the
world's seven richest countries per capita, OK,
that's Luxembourg, Singapore, Ireland, Qatar,
Switzerland, Norway and the United States.
As you see, we're putting a graph up for our
visual audience. And I will describe it to you.
As you see on the left side of the graph,
that's the U.S. that that line that was leading,
we started in first place because we had all the
vaccines and we are now tied for last place with
Switzerland. And Switzerland will soon pass us
because they are vaccinating at a faster rate.
Now, even if you say, sir, let's look at a
different group of countries, this isn't fair.
Yes, we are very economically rich, but
intellectually we are not a very rich
country because of all these morons. Let's look at
something else. Well, even if you look instead at
countries with the biggest populations, you say,
let's look at China, India, Indonesia, Pakistan,
Brazil and the United States, the most populous
countries, you see a clear trend where for now
we are still second in per capita vaccination
among the biggest, most populated countries.
But we have the flattest curve. China
already passed us in per capita vaccination.
Brazil is just about to pass us. India, Indonesia
and Pakistan are vaccinating at far faster rates
than the United States. Now, you could say, well,
David, as they approach our rate of vaccination,
they will slow down and they're not actually
going to pass us wrong. We've already seen
that not be the case with the richest countries.
And there is no evidence is going to be the case
with the largest population countries. Think about
it. We made the vaccines. We bought the vaccines.
We got them earlier. We made them available to
anyone who wants one who wants to. And we are
still within could be weeks, could be a couple
of months. We are going to fall Pathet. Likely
behind in vaccinated percentage of the population
relative to the developed world, the wealthiest
countries, whatever term you want to apply
relative to the most populated countries as well.
Now, just to show you, just as a reminder, because
the people who most want to end all guidelines
are some of the very people who don't want to get
vaccinated. Just to show you what vaccines can do.
You know, everybody's been talking about Israel.
Israel was very fast out of the gate. But the
truth is vaccination rates in Israel have slowed
down. There's like 20 countries that have a higher
vaccination rate than Israel, Denmark, Denmark is
now, I believe it's about 75 percent vaccinated
were 53. They vaccinated 50 percent more
people than us remember, 50 percent more.
Please don't get confused on the math. 75 is 50
percent more than 50. They are wide open. They
have essentially ended all guidelines. I saw a
picture of a concert, huge packed venue, no masks
and cases continue to decline in Denmark. Other
countries are really taking advantage of vaccines
as they become available. It is completely
embarrassing and pathetic what is going on in
the United States. And it's not everyone. It's the
covid-19 boxers who are mostly Republicans. That's
that's the reality of it right now. Look at some
of these other states where we still see under
40 percent vaccination, Wyoming and West Virginia,
they're not even at 40 percent. Idaho, Alabama and
Mississippi, they're at 40 percent on the dot.
Idaho just had to call in the National Guard to
help because it's gotten so bad. We covered that
story last week on the bonus show. And sadly,
some of the very people refusing to take the
vaccine are the ones that say I'm a patriot.
I'm America first. Think about that, what
could be less patriotic than taking a vaccine
that's I'm sorry, what could be less patriotic
than not taking a vaccine that's free in order
to protect your fellow American citizens? And they
won't do it. They claim to love their country and
they say America first. And yet the most populated
countries are passing us and vaccination rate.
The richest countries are passing us and
vaccination rate. It is a living nightmare
partially of our own doing now. I'm not
saying we created the virus. Everybody relax.
But once we had the tools, we did not take
advantage of them the way other countries
are taking advantage of them. And as a result
it is going to be we are going to be sleeping
in this bed that to some degree the Republican
anti-tax movement has made for us. And I want
to keep talking. We also have some new data
I want to talk about that's relevant to this.